tell us a little bit more about this car
project that Apple had been working on
because officially it hadn't given a lot
of details right so starting in 2014
Apple CEO Tim Cook gave a team of
engineers the approval to build the car
going straight out for Detroit and going
right after Tesla and other electric car
makers now after some struggles
internally there's been a change of
direction Apple has put on hold plans to
build a car and is now focusing on an
underlying self-driving system that
could have potentially market to other
car makers did you see the title I
tweeted out for your story Marc no I
missed it what was it titanfall I
thought it was pretty painful titanfall
because the unit was called Titan right
that was the secret name for the Apple
car unit and it seems like from reading
your reporting everything just fell
apart a lack of leadership nobody could
decide on an end goal and they just
basically threw in the towel that's
right there's been a lot of things
happening since the beginning of this
year towards the end of 2015
Steve's desk II was a former Ford
engineer in a previous life and then he
joined Apple in the late 90s to work on
the original iPod many iPhones and such
he was given the approval by Cook to run
this project Apple's team called Titan
like you said hired over a thousand
engineers out of the car industry to
work on this but the deskey left early
in the year then recently one of the
head software engineers on the project
named John Wright left back in May a guy
by the name of Bob Mansfield who led
engineering on many iPhone iPads and
Mac's came back and really analyzed the
progress of the project and decided to
turn toward this self-driving platform
direction
all right so talent is clearly an issue
but you also note in your story that
there are some specific supply chain
issues that held back Apple as well one
of the issues about going into the car
industry is the quality of components
the yields and margins aren't that great
as well as striking those supply chain
deals it's pretty difficult in the
consumer electronics industry Apple has
been known for being one of the best
that really knocking down those deals to
get the best screens the best processors
at the cheapest prices and mass amounts
of volume going into the car industry
and striking those deals is a completely
different animal in itself so
definitely was a roadblock one of many
turned toward Apple building a full-on
full-fledged Tesla competitor well mark
I was originally excited because I
thought well maybe they could actually
do a deal with McLaren then they could
put this self-driving software into a
570 for example but then your colleague
Alex Webb told me the McLaren Group
really isn't McLaren Auto where do you
think they would put this high
technology could they work with Ford for
example it's very possible right now
it's in the early innings we reported in
our story today according to two people
familiar with the matter at the end of
next year around the fall of 2017
Apple's going to decide what to do there
they're going to evaluate the progress
of the self-driving platform and I think
over the next few years we'll see which
car maker is apples choosing to partner
with if any